welcome everybody uh as always we're
excited to be here because I know I say
this all the time but this is another
great episode because it
it is another I mean it is a great
episode it also it's I mean it's set
around something I always wanted to do
when I was in high school which was
model un I thought it was really
interesting and now that I see I missed
out on perhaps some really crazy drama
in the in the general assembly I really
I missed out I don't even know if my
high school had that I've never heard of
it until we did it until we did the
episode I'd never heard of it you didn't
even know about the United Nations do
you where oh you know what that's south
of Dakota okay you got it you got it
yeah
um no this is my car I don't know if I
could drive there I don't know but move
on from there this is a great episode
this is a great episode and it's it is
the treaty written by
the great Harris
whittles who I know you guys have talked
about hairs before but let me just jump
in quickly
um you know as listeners mostly know
Harris has passed away and he was just
one of the best funny
so smart so smart also played you know
he had a recurring role on the show yes
which was hysterical yes who was the guy
he was with um oh with Colton Colton
Dunn who so then he went on to the
superstore yeah yeah he works all the
time but anyway uh Harris whittles is
missed I'll never forget a moment we
were all at the Emmys and they were
doing the in memoriam and it's
interesting but those immemoriums are so
hit and miss like they sometimes they
don't hit certain people like how did
that person not get mentioned or how did
this person get whatever and I was it
was uh Nick was next to me and I think
his wife Megan whatever it was and
Harris's picture came up during the
immemorium and it kinda
like I I it was kind of a
a bit of a slap like a shock not in a
bad way like a like a whoa and then I
look
Nick's eyes are wet my eyes are wet
Megan's eyes I mean it was just
um it was lovely yeah it was lovely that
they did that he certainly deserved that
uh but yeah anyway great guy I just
haven't been here when we've done one of
his episodes no he's I I I I will say
this to anyone I I've never laughed more
from some by someone's humor than
Harrison I love that he's the and is he
the original humble brag did he created
so he he entered the Lexicon it's
unbelievable that is incredible I mean
they really that hypo brag is will go
down forever yeah it's one of the few
things from Parks I think that also
that's entered the Zeitgeist in a way
that you don't even have to know that
Parks and Recreation was a show and you
just know right right we talked about
treat yourself of course I remember he
came out of his office giggling and I
think he said something to the effects
of like I he had talked about it in the
room this idea the concept of a humble
Brad Pitt pretty much that he invented
this idea this word and this Twitter
account that took off off and became a
book and that was a word that we say I
mean I use it I've already died on this
podcast all the time I I um I learned an
immense amount about writing from
Harrison events not about how to be a
person from Harris
um yeah and a lovely family I've met a
lot of them and uh of course heartbroken
for over their situation but they're
just lovely people and um yeah God bless
Harris whittles yes wonderful man
wonderful man